hey guys I just wanted to put out one
more video update on this situation and
I know there's been a lot of video
updates and not a lot of gaming videos
and we're gonna get to that starting
today because two videos a day starts
back up right now and I'm going to be
playing soma immediately after this
which I've been very very looking
forward to but I just want to let you
guys know one because I promised last
week I would and two because I just got
back from South Carolina for the big
musical celebration of Daniels life and
I got to meet up with Ryan and Matt
obviously the video that I put out on
Saturday showed that we're still
committed to making videos once they get
back to LA which should be early
November but I did want to put out this
video to let you guys know that I am
okay you know I can't speak for everyone
else I can't speak for his family and
friends I can't speak for Ryan and Matt
but I wanted to let you guys know that I
personally am okay you know I've
accepted the reality of the situation I
know that Daniel is gone no matter how
much he has impacted our lives I know
that he you know will never be able to
help us out in videos again but I've
accepted that and I am okay and I am
able to move forward I'm able to move
forward with joy in my heart I'm able to
move forward knowing that I'm gonna make
videos that entertain you guys and
that's what I really look forward to and
that's what I really want to do I can't
wait to get started but I needed to put
on this video not just for my own sake
but for letting you guys know a bit more
of who Daniel was because over on the
cyndago Tanel right now is the last
video thats Inigo will upload and it is
about Daniel and it's about Daniel's
life and it's about who Daniel was and
it you know you can't tell a whole
person's life in a short I think it's
like a 13 minute video but it would mean
the world to me if you guys saw that
video because it shows you because some
of you guys didn't know who Daniel was
before all this happened you didn't know
how important he was to our lives you
didn't know what a good friend he was to
us and to his you know friends back home
in South Carolina and his family of
course you know you don't know because
there's not a lot there for you guys to
see so
before I leave and I want this video to
be very short I want you guys to go see
that video there's a link in the
description there'll be an annotation
popping up here that'll get you over to
that video it would really mean a lot if
you did because knowing who he was is so
important to knowing how he inspired us
to move forward in our lives and it'll
give you a sense of why we're so
committed to still making videos and
still entertaining you guys and still
moving forward with our dreams and
ambitions and though he may be gone his
spirit is always going to live on in
what we do so please take the time to go
see this I'm about to go record soma
immediately after this thank you guys so
much for the endless support that you've
shown thank you so much for being there
for us and moving into the future
there's going to be so many cool amazing
new things that we're going to be doing
and a lot of the old stuff because I'm
still gonna be playing games for a long
time coming so thank you guys again so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next movie
bye bye